[Music]
all right good afternoon everybody
well I I wasn't supposed to come here
and my team asked me to come and you
know be a cameo and I tried to be very
short and brief about the you know kind
of opening up this spot
you know life sessions you know Google I
mean well this morning I mean you guys
were in the keynote and we had a you
know kind of three new IOT product
announcements and and it's actually
shows you know kind of insight on the
what Google is really actually doing and
and the vision or strategy that that
we're taking we you know the the
interest we are seeing in in the field
that a lot of you know the customer is
having the IOT the problems and the
applications and we see there are is
this is an opportunity because it's
actually worded a lot of data being
generated and Google is essentially a
data company and and we our mission is
to organize what you know data and and
so and that is the kind of we see as you
know this an area where we our core
strengths in you know in AI and big data
and you know and also a lot of this you
know
the analytics solutions and those things
can actually be a big instrument for our
lot of our customers and and also
providing the access to organize this
data and access to a lot of them our key
strategy as you probably actually
guessed is really and you know really AI
first in you know bringing AI as a
really front and center of everything
and so the first the announcement that
we had was about the HTTP you is a
custom hardware
you know accelerator for the running
tensorflow light model and and then you
know that's actually really optimized
for the performance support dollar and
performance for you know power
consumption that actually gives you
really it kind of really enables love
applications you can imagine it's a you
know when this TPU can be combined with
you know microcontroller you know that
actually make you know doing running
some processing and and doing an
infrared output and combined with the
you know like security chip that
actually provide the rule of trust you
know for and then of the encryptions and
that that actually really can actually
be very disruptive and in the market and
creating new opportunities like making
every things in the world really an
intelligent and providing brain you know
at a very low cost and with very high
power efficiency and without
compromising the performance and that's
kind of really a small peek into what
we're doing but it actually we were
building really the whole end-to-end
story of the you know
the cloud infrastructure for IOT and
then also the edge and we're doing this
not just by ourselves we're actually
with the in partnership with many
partners and there are certain areas
that Google can do you know a good job
and because we know our algorithms and
we know how how to optimize for them and
then we also make those you know the
solutions actually available to our
partners for them actually to make the
product out of there or so we also
recommend our partners to you know to
our customers and vice versa so actually
you know we drive on this ecosystem with
the partners and as as well as our own
technology innovations you know and you
know really pulling our own weight as a
Google so today we have a really
beautiful you know session and a lot of
good information and about more detailed
information about Google's strategy on
you know IOT intelligence and security
and we have a you know good set of
customers going to speak at the panel
and so I'm very excited to have all of
you and then you know and without much
to delay I'm gonna open it up to the
next speaker thank you very much thank
you in tone so last session of the day
so thank you for being here how excited
are we about IOT there were 17 sessions
yeah 17 sessions on IOT a big keynote
announcement a lot of good news I'm
really excited to be here and talk about
our vision for IOT I'm Anthony password
I had the product management team for
cloud IOT offering and really excited to
be here so you we all know we're living
in a connected world there's really no
no surprise now that IOT is real what's
really changed is that I could talk
about the billions of devices that are
very going to be connected but the
realities we
moving from connectivity to intelligence
because without real intelligence
without real insights or actionable
actionable insights on the data that's
generated by those devices it's really
hard to get a real return on investment
so intelligence is key to those
investments and the problem is those
devices are generating a huge amount of
data and when we're looking at how much
data that that is an IDC study into said
that in 2025 there's going to be about
40 billion zettabyte of data generated
by IOT devices and most of it is
actually a real-time and 40 zettabyte of
data is about what 40 billion petabyte
of data if i'm not mistaken that's
fairly sizable amount of data but the
problem is that with that much data how
do you get inside of the data how do you
analyze that data to really make
meaningful decisions it's really about
you know all that data all that insight
is really about connecting devices with
application and people in a seamless way
in a non disruptive way it's really that
data that's the glue between all those
all those pieces of the puzzle and we're
trying to solve here oops
going the wrong way so Google has been
in the IOT for quite some time
especially working with intelligence on
devices so intelligence in the
thermostat intelligence in the car
intelligence in how you interact with
your home devices with a home gateway
and we've really learned from from all
those experiences internal experiences
and brought last year a new platform
called IOT core cloud IOT core that's
ecology core is a managed service it's
available in your in your console today
if you go to your DCP console it is a
managed service you don't have to
configure it it scales up and down for
you it will allow you to connect
millions of devices securely to the
cloud very easily from little POC of a
few devices to millions of devices with
no issues we're really trying to
productize IOT core the same way you
know bring that innovation to the public
to our customers the same way we did
with big data tools in the past like you
know if syndrome Oh
Hadoop HBase came from internal
that came out and were delivered to our
customers so a little bit about same
philosophy here for IOT we've seen great
adoption since our launch I mean some
great customers will hear about smart
parking no a curb EP as well will be
will be on stage so we've seen that
traction of customer really transforming
their business with IOT really finding
new business model finding efficiencies
finding optimization everywhere they can
so it's all about operational insights
all about business processes and
managing their assets transforming their
business with IOT and it's talking to
those customers we're really looking at
know how we're going forward so talking
about customers I would like to bring on
stage a Kirby P and Charton from a Kirby
rottenness who's been using the platform
so a Kirby P is an oil and gas company
based around no way and they've been
using you know some other platform the
GCP platform through a partner called
Cod night and they're doing pretty
maintenance and all that but Charton
tell us more about a Kirby P Thank You
Anthony
a kbp is a upstream oil and gas company
based in Norway we are the fourth
biggest company listed on the Norwegian
stock exchange so big in a Norwegian
scale just short of 2,000 employees and
have a daily production of a bit more
than 150,000 barrels of oil take a BP as
we know we're today is the result of a
merger of a small Norwegian company
called in Ostia with a very dynamic
culture and also the big enterprise the
BP side bps asset in Norway it's a
pretty impressive growth for a year now
what are kind of the key challenges that
occur bp's facing and how is IOT helping
with those challenges I think I can beep
you have the same challenges as a lot of
the upstream oil and gas companies on
the top like we our industry that's
quite heavy and we have the potential to
have quite a bit of impact on the
environment so I would say HSE or really
safety and environment is really always
on top so that's something that we
really like to use digital for and of
course profitability that's driving the
own cost
increases so yeah so how is that helping
like how is IOT helping with those I
think there are in several different
areas I think they actually one of the
things that we see quite good result
from it's actually very simple it's just
that based on the work that cognate is
doing they are extracting a lot of data
we are pulling up to a million data
point a second into a Google store and
based on these data when we get them
contextualized in the right way and push
it back to the operators out on the
platforms that really helps driving
better decisions not really being very
advanced of course also predictive
maintenance kind of predicting events is
very important and I think also this
data really drives opportunities within
kind of moving people out of dangerous
sounds and also moving over to a kind of
unmanned platform that's something we
are kind of leading on also in our way
that's great anything else you'd like to
add about know your usage of GCP
platform anything yeah I think we are
really impressed of the speed of the GCP
platform and I think also as an industry
we are kind of unfortunately a bit slow
movers and I think also the work that we
are doing with Google really helps us
moving faster I think that's really good
well Jordan thank you very much thank
you for your trust in the platform
looking forward to innovate so fantastic
use case you know predictive maintenance
everything it's it's it's we really love
to work with a kirby P so as we're
looking now to the future and a little
bit of our vision around IOT really
looking at IOT through four main pillars
one is around intelligence everywhere
you've seen this morning we announced
our edge strategy this is really about
expanding all the AI and email
capabilities down closer to where it's
needed server lace Calvary I've talked a
little bit about clarity core and how
technology core server less and scalable
we're really trying to make that across
the entire value chain of our offering
security always number one priority for
us and security is actually complicated
there's a lot
pieces that we have to deal with you
know it's from the manufacturing process
to the boot of a device to the
communication to the back-end services
so we'll talk about that and obviously
our system of partners IOT is not of a
game you play alone you have to play
with partners and you have to build an
ecosystem in every place of the value
chain as well so we really value
building a big echo system for our
partners and for our customers sorry
so it's dive a little bit into
intelligence at the intelligence
everywhere and particularly where we go
with the edge so Google has been known
and is known today for a lot of the m/l
and AI innovation and the tools that
we're providing in this conference
you've heard about bigquery ml you've
heard about Auto ml coming out you've
heard about no probably about cloud ml
and gene I mean all those tools that
were building to really democratize the
AI in democratize ml for our customers
really trying to bring all that power to
our customers and this is particularly
true and image recognition for example
with Auto ml vision that's a very
impressive tool that you can get you can
get to use very quickly without being
really a data scientist so we're glad
we've been at this too this morning
actually to introduce our cloud IOT edge
there is actually another session
tomorrow morning at 9:30 that drills
into IOT edge this is really listening
to our customers saying I love you AI
but I have some constraints at the edge
that I can't really use your cloud
platform to do that sometimes my
internet my internet connectivity is
down in the case of a curve VP sometimes
it's no it's boats that are going they
can't be connected
sometimes it's because the bandwidth
constraint you heard about LG this
morning they're taking pictures no more
hundreds of pictures all the time they
can send all those pictures to the cloud
to do the inference and come back they
have to do it on-site sometimes it's
compliance you have to get the data you
have to leave the data on site and you
can't send it outside of your premise
and there's a lot of reasons why edge
makes total sense and we're trying to
bridge between cloud and edge together
so cloud IOT edge is actually two
components one is our edge ml component
which
run time to run tensorflow light model
and to get a tensorflow light model you
take a tensor flow model that you train
maybe we've got em with a male engine or
with cloud GPUs in the cloud and you
will compile that model for you into a
tensor flow light model and send it to
the device how do we send it we have a
Jo T core which manages the security the
connectivity with the cloud or the local
processing local storage anything you
need you would expect as an edge device
that's gonna that's endo by edge IOT
core this is in alpha right now there's
an early access program that you can
sign up for today to get access to this
this runtime can run on android things
which is a fully secure and manage OS so
that's a full OS manage the same way
when manage an Android device or phone
except it's four things so it's been
optimized and we're also going to
support Linux OS as well and the big
announcement was the hardware
accelerator so edge ml will support
obviously standard CPU general purpose
CPU or GPU or rhtp you so HTTP you was
probably the most exciting thing I don't
know if you followed the news a little
bit there were so many tweets I was like
whoa this is actually pretty impressive
so people tend to like it so you're
seeing a little bit of the size here you
can fit four or five of them on a coin
very small edge TPU has been really
worked in collaboration with the AI
research team our software team and the
hardware team together to really bring a
very purpose-built hardware for
inference of machine learning models so
it's really that that collaboration
between the AI research and the hardware
that make it possible with a very big
focus on performance per watt and
performance per dollars trying to make
it cost effective so it can be
everywhere and trying to make it very
low-power so it doesn't consume a lot of
power you can put in on smaller devices
you don't have to have you know big big
hit sync and things like that so we
really believe that those this HTP you
will transfer them just dumb data
collectors into smart collectors and
smart devices and open up a whole range
of new user applications so this is
really really exciting so the goal of
cloud IOT edge if I summarize it's to
enhance a personal reliability you know
making sure it can work anytime you
don't have to worry about loss of
connectivity with IOT core you can
really deploy those models to the cloud
and to the edge sorry and apply them
where you need them most in real time
very low latency we always focus on
security obviously for the secure
connectivity with a JIT core and keeping
it cost-effective in any scale because
the the the more cost-effective the more
there's gonna be out there we also
thought about how do you marry edge and
cloud in a very close loop of learning
and that was very important to us we
didn't just released an edge product we
wanted to make sure that edge product is
an extension of your cloud in a
closed-loop learning so if this is a
kind of a visualization of know the data
flowing into IOT edge you can do some
learning here you can do some inference
here if you want but you can send the
data through IOT core to the cloud put
it in a database of your choice or data
repository choice retrain your model
with cloud GPUs potentially then send
that model back to the device to edge
edge IOT IOT edge to have a local
execution so that close do be very
important because those devices are not
static anymore it's not just you send an
email model and let it be you'll improve
it over time things can change new new
problems can be detected with the images
and you need to be able to really
effectively move those models update
those models through a through this
lifecycle so we've seen you know LG this
morning and manufacturing very great use
case this is a million-dollar saving per
line that's pretty impressive just you
know by putting that intelligence at the
edge in retail you can think about hyper
personalization of offers this is a
augmented reality view where no
discounts could be given to you based on
who you are and your purchasing habits
you know the motive collision-avoidance
you know detecting if somebody's looking
at their phone you know that's that's
pretty it would be pretty neat I would
avoid a lot of accidents I mean there's
a lot of notes
traffic crowding there's a lot of
application for 4ml so those are just a
few examples where we've seen traction
with some of our customers so if I show
you if we showed you the little TPU if I
give you that little TPU today you're
gonna be a little bit trouble you won't
know what to do with it so we created a
little some that I have here that some
it's a system on modules it's a full
module which has a quad-core CPU on it
has a Wi-Fi has obviously a route of
trust and a crypto from microchip and it
has the HTTP you of the C forget this
one so this is the this is a some that's
production grade so you can actually
produce a lot of them this will be
available in October so you can buy this
in October and start playing with it the
other thing that we did because same
thing if I give you this you won't be
able to do much that we created that
development board this is our Y team
created the development board so I can
just slap this thing on it like this and
I clip it I'm not gonna do it I did it I
was good and then you have a full system
you know with a Gigabit Ethernet and USB
C's and all the things HDMI you can
connect a camera to it you can GPIO so
you can really play with that thing
and really get going this also will be
available in October for you to play
with so we also work with partners on
the edge TPU sites are really working
with my connector vendors and some of
the device analytics vendors to leverage
the edge TPU you know in to solutions
for our customers so some of those
partners who are building either
gateways or are really leveraging the
the HTTP you for their use cases so
we're try to really start kickstart that
ecosystem of partners focused on H GPU
and application of the HTTP you for for
our customers and and for you so let's
talk about scalability now that you're
all excited about HTTP you you're gonna
have a lot of devices with intelligence
you're going to need some scalable
infrastructure in the backend so IOT
core words as I said earlier was really
meant to be completely serverless
and you can start with one device
connected and ramped up to you know
millions of devices in production
without
really having to shard having to plan
for memory CPU anything it's just
everything is done for you and you're
just gonna pay as you go and this allows
you to go from POCs to pilot to a small
deployment to your production really
with no effort and that's really a big
big game-changer we think in terms of
how it helps you in your digital
transformation journey so we innovated
in the edge obviously we also kept
innovating on the IOT core itself and
those are some of the features some are
better some are a little more early for
example the clarity provisioning service
that's that's an early access so this
one is about enabling you to onboard and
provision literally millions of devices
we had to have without having to go
one-by-one and provision them so if
you're buying a bunch of crypto for
example with microchip you buy all the
script O's they're gonna give you a real
ID and some information you just put
that in in the cloud IOT provisioning
system and all those IDs will be moved
to your accounts so you don't have to do
that manually we did things like gateway
which is a way to pass through the
authentication of IP or non IP devices
pass that authentication to the cloud
directly so the gateway is not the proxy
for all you really authenticate the
devices behind the gateway even though
they may not be IP devices so that's
that's an interesting one we do groups
we do high speed messages to the device
if you need 100 messages per second down
to the device we can do that now and we
added some extensive logging
capabilities to debug your system so a
lot of features we're gonna keep going
like that throughout the rest of the
year and next year
this is kind of the core system being
improved now we'd like to welcome
another customer that is really changing
the game in farming so John Friedman
from frayed farm freight farm near and
you know all know about Airbnb disrupted
hospitality we kind of view frayed farm
is disrupting the agriculture so I'm
happy to welcome Fred from I think
before we start we're gonna see a video
that's right so I don't if I click for
this or not know
[Music]
excellent well thanks and welcome to
intelidox more about print form yeah
sure happy to
I did notice a few people kind of look
at their their session description I
know you're dealing a lot with
containers as it relates to the GCP
through that's this is a little bit
different container so you're gonna be
finding out about that today
but we use that as a pivotal piece of
our infrastructure we feel that shipping
containers and IOT are actually great
building blocks for the next level of
food we're looking to lower the barrier
of entry for anybody who's trying to get
into farming and make food supply a lot
more accessible so getting into this we
started looking at the data but we were
surprised to find there's not a lot of
data in agriculture and one of the
biggest industries in the world really
hard to find consistent data to build
around and the reason for that is
there's a few reasons for that actually
one there's not a lot of environments
that are exactly the same so if you have
a farm in one place of the world and
another farm halfway across the world
the results they're getting and the
things that they're doing they're not
going to match up so so all that data is
very siloed another reason is as farms
have been consolidated over the years
that generational knowledge hasn't been
passed down so we're in a very
centralized global food supply system
and the things that have been leveraged
are the crops the chemical and the
genetic attributes of the crops have
been really focused on and the ones have
been prioritized are the ones that can
withstand things like drought are
resistant to pests and they can travel
really far and hang out on the shelves
for a long time so you knows I didn't
really say anything about taste or
variety or flavor anything like that so
if you are a chef and you're looking to
get a unique thing on your menu and you
want to make a dish that's just very
signature to you that's gonna be a
really hard task with our current food
system yeah if you're in sourcing or
you're in any type of food business
where you're trying to bring innovation
to it it's gonna be very difficult for
you to get something that's only grown
in a specific part of the world shipped
all the way to you in the quantity that
you need so it's very familiar to
minimum order quantities you see in
global manufacturing so what we were
inspired by was actually 3d printers and
that technology and how that shifted a
segment that really couldn't get into
the game of prototyping or a small run
manufacturing and put that in their
hands so a lot more innovation could
happen right so that's where we came in
and said hey is there a way that we can
build a platform that's accessible to
everyone uses some infrastructure that
or existed in the world that everyone
has some logistic support for that's the
shipping container and IOT which allows
us to get a lot of that transparency and
traceability that everyone's looking for
you so tell us more about IOT then yeah
how is that helping so i io T is what
creates those environments in the farm
so it's Internet of it the environment
for us right when our customers are
looking at the farm they're leaning at
all the components that make up the
perfect scenario inside the unit so
let's say you're just getting started I
Oh T is going to be what basically sets
the environment around a certain crop
attribute and heightens that across the
way so let me give you an example if you
are if you are looking into IOT as a way
to Orchestra orchestrate all the
different components you can in any
environment create an environment that's
halfway across the world so we have
customers in Puerto Rico to buy Detroit
all over the place and inside that farm
it's the perfect day of summer every day
of the year it's a very unique
environment in there we can also create
environments that are not of this worlds
with IOT so you could take the nutrients
composition of Italy and you can match
that with the air quality of Salinas
Valley pair that with the co2 density
that would be next to a active volcano
as well as giving a bit plant the light
spectrum that it really wants I really
wanted to taste that lettuce no don't
you so yeah so I use a really essential
piece for us to build these
environmental recipes to match what's
out there in the world but also to
create things that aren't of this world
so your customers the the chefs are the
farmers yeah they use a mobile app to do
all that I think that's right can you
show us maybe what do you have here yeah
give you a little spray the demo good
see it looks like it's casting so can we
cast the on the screen yeah oh yeah Wow
okay so what are we seeing here that's a
real farm right that's right so I will
keep it upright
for this demo so this is what any farmer
who's bought a leafy green machine
that's what a free farm is called they
would see this no matter where they are
in the world inside the farm they might
use it as their remote control so they
wanted to turn something on and off
really quickly they're gonna use this
same app so let's for instance this is
actually a live farm in Boston
Massachusetts right now okay this is at
our headquarters so let's go ahead and
we're gonna turn on the lights so all
the devices are connected we're just
going to beautiful we just turn that on
and now if we do a quick refresh we
should see the lights start to turn on
in succession you'll also notice that
the front lights are linked to the back
right lights of the front left lights
and the back left lights so that ability
to pair linked and create relationships
within the farm is all within their
fingertips we can also set programs and
around that we do call them recipes yeah
and I'll talk a little bit more about
that no let's say I've turned a few
things on and I really like what I got
growing there but I want to track kind
of what that's doing to the rest of the
farm so you can pull up your historical
analysis
and see what effect maybe one of the
things that you've turned on has on
another thing in the farm so that's
great because you can really start to
tune the balance of things based on your
needs so you'll be able to look at
things like water temperature pH the
amount of nutrients that are in the
water co2 in the air humidity
temperature and there's a whole range of
devices that you can pair create
dependencies around put on timers things
like that so let's say I'm really happy
with what I got here well I'm gonna go
over to the program section these are
all of the things that you can map out
different dosing schedules different
learning timers set different day and
night times and then you can save that
recipe you can save that recipe is a
unique thing for you or maybe you want
to get another farm that's halfway
around the world say you're a chain
restaurant and you want to have a unique
lettuce on your bun that can be
something that you save and pour it to
all of your farms but you can also pull
from a community of recipes that other
farmers have created or we have created
for you to improve your performance of
your farm so actually last year we
developed a recipe to improve the
efficiency of all models all the way
back to 2015 and updated all those farms
at once so with this and with cloud IOT
we see this is a way that we can
continuously improve these farms over
time use machine learning tools to
basically do this updating for us and
always choose the best path excellent
well done this is awesome thank you very
much addressed thank you thanks
let's talk about security you know
Security's almost my favorite projects
that's where I started my career
actually so I've always been keen on
having great security for us and know I
go we take security obviously very
seriously and trying to look at it from
the ground of the Google cloud platform
itself is built from the ground up with
security in mind and IOT core is built
on top of that platform so we really try
to think about security from an annual
and end-to-end standpoint you're going
from the devices the connectivity the
edge the platform itself and the
application but today I really want to
focus more on the device side rather
than the cloud side by now you probably
have seen a lot of session around that
and one thing we've done differently
when we launched IOT core is the way you
offend ticket devices to the cloud we
use what we call a token so I mean we
don't call it's a standard it's called a
JSON web token it's pretty common to
authenticate against api's so we use a
jot token to do the authentication of
the device to the cloud the cloud is
authenticated through a standard TLS
session but then the device uses a jot
that it signs with a private key and
authenticate itself with a corresponding
public key in IOT core has the same
level of security as a TLS mutual
authentication but it has a lot of
benefits has no dependency on the TLS
stack it's very small in footprint it's
you can easily upgrade your TLS stack
without disrupting your application and
it can also a Santa Kate non IP devices
because non IP devices can create a jot
pass it to our gateway and send it to
cloud for authentication so a lot of a
lot of really good benefits and actually
to demonstrate the power of this we have
partnered with microchip to release
actually what is fundamental analogy
this is the first 8-bit MCU that is
securely cloud connected yes this is the
first a B MCU that is cloud connected
this is really a revolution because a
bit it's been there for many years 15 20
years people have been buying a bit
people know what they are they're cheap
they're really available but until now
everybody was saying I know for IOT
32-bit let's go Billy
go big well actually you don't need to
you can take this 8-bit and because our
stack is so small because you use a
joking to authenticate devices then
entire JA authentication can be handled
by a crypto that's on there and the the
whole TLS is in the Wi-Fi module itself
so because it's so small it fits in
there if you use material off you cannot
do that so this is only kind of Google
specific question if I can so this is
really a cool thing this is this is
going to come probably around October
will be available around October for you
to purchase but this will really put IOT
everywhere very securely which is super
important so finally let's talk about
our ecosystem we talked about the
ecosystem of each corner that's great
but there's really a lot of partners
that we we want to work with one one
noticeable ecosystem that we like we in
May this year we actually announced that
we joined the lower Alliance we really
like that connectivity layer so we're
working with partners like the thing
networks or obvious in France or my
devices all really good partner in the
Laura space that's something we really
like and we're going to pursue our
effort into we will really look at
partners across the entire spectrum from
device partners to application partners
to service partners you know to really
serve and to end solutions to our
customers so this is just a sample of
some of the incredible partners we have
and we're really happy to support our
goal is to make our partners successful
so our customers are successful and
that's really key to our strategy when
we partner so now I want to bring Jen
Bennett John Bennett is part of our
office of the CTO and she's been working
with many many customers helping them in
their digital transformation and so
Jen's going to talk about a few customer
use case and how she's trying to create
a an ecosystem of businesses actually so
Jen thank you right thank you very much
it's great thanks to our customer
so you know Anthony mentioned that
there's a number of industries that are
being transformed by IOT and to be
honest with you there's not a customer
that I've talked to that hasn't been
thinking about or embarking on a journey
in IOT so it is transforming all
industries and across the business from
customer engagement to product lifecycle
management to risk management and even
operational efficiencies and
effectiveness so it's really this idea
of transformation within within the
industry and as we think about that you
know this is really a catalyst for new
business opportunities Society data and
not only that creating ecosystems that
can leverage the data in new ways to
drive new value so why you embark on an
IOT journey maybe for one particular
reason but then that data starts to
become invaluable in a number of
different business cases this idea of
democratizing data is really really key
to the future of IOT let's look at an
example so this is a customer of ours so
- out of Europe not too dissimilar to -
here in the in in the in North America
provides automotive services to their
customers and they do this across a
number of European countries but with
the growth of the connected car they
could see that their market was being
disrupted and in their words they said
we had an opportunity to be daring to
disrupt ourselves and become part of
this connected ecosystem and so -
partnered up with Z who provides an obd
to dongle that attaches to the vehicle
to provide data from the vehicle and
then they partnered up with a DCP or the
Google Cloud partner tell me + who
specializes in building machine learning
models and these machine learning models
that they built were all around
predicting failures in this particular
case they started with battery failures
you're in your vehicle you go to start
it it doesn't start not a delightful
experience so again - partnered up with
Z who partnered up oh and created this
ecosystem with tell me + to build a
machine learning model that could take
this data from the
I'll predict battery failures of course
this is only the start there's many
other things that they're going to do
but what this enabled them to do was to
become a driver companion to their
customer so now they've built an app
that can provide information about the
maintenance schedules that can provide
information about predictions on what
might be coming and happening it can
also provide geolocation information and
many many other things in the future
they've become the driver companion and
part of the ecosystem of course they're
looking to roll this out to about a
hundred thousand customers but it
doesn't stop there this data you can
imagine can be leveraged for them to
drive down their operational costs
managing their inventory having that
spare part available before you even get
there I don't know how many of you have
taken your vehicle in only to find out
they didn't have the part you needed it
just happened to me recently and so and
then not only that but who else could
value from the state of the OEM the
vehicle manufactures all this plethora
of data that they can now leverage to
understand their customer better it's an
ecosystem it's an ecosystem built on
data I'd like to welcome up Jon heard
from smart parking a CTO of smart
parking maybe you should shut a little
bit more insight on another example all
related to smart say-so John welcome
Thank You Jin maybe give us a brief
overview of what you do with smart
parking yes thank you everybody for
being here and let me just tell you a
little bit about smart parking we're a
company based out of Melbourne Australia
but we have offices in New Zealand where
we do our development and we have sites
and 17 countries around the world where
we are about reinventing the parking
experience for you for various customer
experiences so there also there are the
customer experience for the enforcement
officer I know you hate them but making
their lives efficient and much much more
effective changing the experience of
finding a car park that's in a city so
that you know that a car park is just
around the corner you don't need to keep
driving round and round looking for that
car spaces they may not be there we also
provide payment and and interaction for
allowing you to do payment for your
parking right there in the seconds from
your smartphone or also connecting to
your existing infrastructure the payment
machines on the streets or and and by
the way we do both on the road parking
and also off street parking in multi
stories and so where you see some car
parking spaces where they have the red
and green guidance lights that's that's
the sort of stuff that we do around the
world great maybe tell us a little bit
about some of the challenges that led
you to partner up with Google good
question as we have been starting to
talk more and more whether customers
we're seeing a change in the
conversation that we're having with our
customers is no longer just about
parking it's actually about how do we
change the city experience how do we
make our lives within our environments
more effective and efficient and parking
because it's actually a well understood
you know we know about paying for our
parking it pays for that initial
establishment of the IOT infrastructure
for a city and so what we're seeing is
that that smart parking is actually
deploying and delivering the initial
pillar which or tentpole which enables a
city to start to broaden their
intelligence services within the city so
it it reaches out into other things such
as public broadband and smart rubbish
bins or garbage man's smart street
lighting and so on you know it's it's
essentially unlimited but that required
us to look at the characteristics of
what that type of information now
requires we need to connect to anything
because if that central gateway on this
on the street lamppost is doing parking
it's also now going to need to connect
to other things and so we needed a new
class of system that was not just about
parking not just about just dealing with
those transactions for parking but
essentially connecting to anything
communicating with anything
and then processing their information
and smart ways which not just about
parking
but for smart cities council that we've
talked a lot about edge talked to us a
little bit about edge and your thoughts
on this yeah age is really critical to
our real-world you know as we know
sometimes when you try to make a phone
call you can't connect sometimes when
you have really time-dependent things
the time it takes to do a communication
transaction to a back-end computer you
know cloud system may be too long an
example is we we process many many many
many thousands of images per day and we
recognize the number place of cars and
that number plate is used to raise a
barrier on because you've registered for
example to go into that car parking lot
now if that barrier arm does not open
within about two seconds you're starting
to create a queue of vehicles outside
that parking space and that really
becomes critical especially at you know
10:00 to 9:00 in the morning when you
need to get into the office well more
importantly it creates congestion also
so the edge computing just one example
of how the edge computing is really
critical is to do that processing in
real time right there where you need
that information and that edge computing
needs to be quite intelligent as well
and that's actually what we're so
excited about the HTTP you capabilities
because we can start to do a whole
variety of intelligence right at the
edge to guarantee real-time licensing
that's just one example fantastic you
know I talked it was talking to a
retailer and you know they always think
about inside the four walls and I said
you know one of my biggest frustrations
is finding a car spot so when I talk
about ecosystems it's like how can we
take now that smart parking that
navigates you through that the journey
that you do in a day you know whether
you're parking to go into a building or
going to the store right so this
ecosystem and you know I know that you
you probably face this quite a bit it's
it's really about how do we start to
enable easy exactly you know it was
interesting John just commented about
you know the Internet of farm-in and I
was just thinking as he was speaking
we're creating the Internet of parking
for you
what we're doing and actually that's the
mission that I feel very passionate
about we're reinventing that experience
and it's it's an experience that we
currently live with and it sucks and so
the opportunity here of not just the
parking and changing that dynamic but
making it more cohesive and more
personalized to what I'm trying to do is
not just about parking usually I'm
parking there for some other reason
right I'm trying to get to a store I'm
trying to get to the office or trying to
do something else and it's an
inconvenience right now
and that's what we're our mission is
today you guys have been a tremendous
partner and we thank you for your
partnership and thank you for joining us
today thanks Jim so you know as we think
about connected things you know one of
the things that's really critical in IOT
is this idea of location intelligence
and Anthony mentioned Google's you know
we've done a lot with connected things
but it's no surprise I'm sure that we
have a lot of work into location
intelligence so if we take you know the
very best of maps and routes and places
and we start to apply it to things like
asset tracking or perhaps efficient
routing for some of the most complex
fleet itineraries tracking or
visualizing your connected assets most
importantly no matter where they are all
around the world right
this is geolocation both inside and
outside geocoding distance matrix real
time traffic real time Road conditions
all at your fingertips such a key asset
to the ecosystem of IOT and we're very
very proud of of the work that we've
done in collaboration with our Maps team
as well so no matter what you're
tracking you know this solution that's
integrated because solution can really
help you start to manage your your
bottom line grow your top line and
manage the risk as well let's look at a
few examples so Vagabond is a company
that provides technology and operations
for the food and beverage service
industry so vending machines and they
embarked on this journey of an IOT
solution where they connected vending
machines getting information about stock
getting information about the cash and
in the vending machine but what they
were really looking forward to combined
with that was this idea of precise
geolocation and you can imagine these
vending machines may not always be in
the easiest places to locate it could be
in the third floor dormitory or it could
be in a back alley right so this idea of
having world-class geolocation was
really really critical and now they can
overlay that vending machine information
on precise location so that their
drivers can be very efficiently routed
for restocking activity and they've been
able to drive some tremendous
improvements in terms of the that both
the top-line growth as well as managing
their bottom line and theft
so theft has been reduced about 15% off
the top line so some really great
example another example is a company out
of Australia called fleet minder and
they provide a vehicle and asset
tracking solutions in about 12 countries
and really what they wanted to do was be
able to visualise the location of these
vehicles and combine it with some of
their GPS technology that they have
giving dispatchers not only location
information but really optimize routes
and so you can actually see now even
surrounding the real-time surrounding
information and really start to drive a
whole lot of use cases for example being
able to understand maintenance activity
and where the closest maintenance shop
would be for that for that driver some
really great results from fleet fleet
minder about a 50% decrease in overtime
which if anybody who's been in the
trucking industry this is a huge problem
and a huge cause of turnover is their
time away from home so some incredible
efficiencies that have been gained
through doing some of these things
not to mention really reducing the
incorrect deliveries so this has been
really game-changing in terms of their
business volume so we talked about IOT
delivering new insights Anthony
mentioned intelligence we talked about
intelligence at the edge we've talked
about scalability and really taking the
opportunity to drive new business and we
talked about how how IOT is enabling an
ecosystem
I'd really like to pull all those pieces
together with you and share a video so
can we roll the video please
West Oakland is surrounded by three
major freeways and it is downwind of the
Port of Oakland which is a fifth largest
port in the country the community is the
real blend of land it's only been
recently in the past half century that
we realized that this is a bad layout
for public health we clusters cancers
related to what makes airborne food so
dangerous and that they are not always
visible to the human eye EDF and Google
brought together other partners to
collect measure and analyze air
pollution data in Oakland Oakland
Oakland aah who put a few key parts with
their Atlanta environmental intelligence
platform which attach the scientific
grade air quality measurements what
we've done is many tries basically an
air quality laboratory into the car so
it's able to provide high quality
measurement fast high-resolution iya
partnered with academic scientists to
analyze the data that we received from
the Google Street View cars the
measurement and analysis have shown
elevated levels of black carbon and
nitrogen oxide in Oakland these types of
air pollutants typically come from the
burning of fossil fuels cars trucks and
other industrial sources we're really
beginning to see in much higher detail
but the air we breathe on the ground
looks like we hope this new data can
empower local communities and community
groups to advocate for cleaner air
[Music]
so you can see quite an ecosystem
already being formed around collection
of data from vehicles in Eric pollution
but this ecosystem is growing even more
in May of this year Kaiser joined into
the ecosystem and now what they've done
is take that data and combined it with
electronic medical records from
residents who live in this area and did
a study around how that is impacting a
block by bike analysis of the health
risks from air pollution the most
detailed analysis of its kind so we're
really really proud of this partnership
this ecosystem that's forming to solve
new problems to solve old problems with
new approaches really really thrilled
about this so you know if you want to
learn more about IOT we have a breakout
session tomorrow in the morning
Anthony mentioned this about the IOT
edge we have a showcase on the at the
I'm sorry we have an IOT area in the
showcase in Moscone South but we also
have a lot of information online and I
encourage you to go there and check it
out with that our session will will be
completed I'd ask for you to provide any
feedback in the mobile app and I hope
and thank you for joining us once again
I'd like to thank John from freight
farms I'd like to thank John from smart
parking and I'd like to thank jarton
from acre BP tremendous customers
tremendous partners and I hope you guys
have a rest of the great rest of the
next event thanks so much for coming
[Music]